what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another edition of what the
hell'd that I just read I was emailed
another season a plot leaked but I have
to admit this one is much better than
the last one I read to you but I have to
give a disclaimer because I don't know
if any of this is real or not but I did
enjoy reading it nonetheless
ever since the season 7 plot leaked was
proven to be real why was afraid
everyone was gonna make their own fake
plot leaks and just pass them off as
being real since people may be more
inclined to believing them since season
sevens plot leaked was so accurate even
though it did sound ridiculous so I kind
of approached this one the same way the
plot leaked that I am about to read to
you does have a lot of things in it that
sound very plausible but it also has
some things that sound just as crazy as
trying to go capture a white so with
that in mind I guess anything could
happen next
whoever posted this outline on reddit
apparently deleted their account shortly
after that which I thought was weird
because that's what the same person did
the last time and theirs ended up being
99% accurate so I figured what the hell
I'll give it a look and I'll read it to
everyone who wants to listen if you
don't give two shits about it then
hopefully you didn't click on this video
but to everyone else who likes to be
entertained regardless I hope you enjoy
this because it is interesting to say
the least let's just get right into it
season 8 episode 1 torment and barracks
survived the attack on the wall torment
rides to Winterfell to meet with Jon
while barrack stays behind at the wall
Cersei and Qyburn discuss ideas about
how to defeat Daenerys and her dragons
Cersei orders Qyburn to mass-produce
ballistas and she also orders alchemists
to make new pots of wildfire they get
interrupted by news of Euron arriving in
King's Landing with the golden company
Jon and Daenerys arrive at Winterfell
many northern Lords are angry about Jon
bending the knee to Daenerys but Saens
and Arya give Jon their full support
Theon Greyjoy arrives at King's Landing
to free Yara who is imprisoned inside
the silence while Euron is greeting with
Cersei and the golden company commander
Theon tries to free Yara but he gets
captured by Euron's men Samwell Tarly
reads a book about how to create
Valyrian steel the process requires
dragonglass
and Dragonfire John as Gendry if he can
make new Valyrian steel swords John also
has Daenerys if one of her dragons can
provide the fire
Daenerys agrees because she knows the
importance of the situation
Qyburn begins to examine the remains of
the dead white that was left at the
dragon pit season 8 episode 2 Bryan
tells John that he is a Targaryen named
Aegon he is the son of Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna Stark the heir to the Iron
Throne John says he has no desire to sit
on the Iron Throne and he also says Ned
will always be his father
John decides not to tell Daenerys what
bran taught him
Tyrion receives a letter from King's
Landing Cersei says she will be sending
the golden company who will be led by
the mountain they will be coming to
Winterfell to join the fight against the
army of the dead Jaime Lannister arrives
at Winterfell to help join the fight
against the army of the dead John goes
to brain in the godswood he has brain if
he can see the night King the same way
he did at the wall he wants to know the
night King's movements bran wargs into
some crows and we follow them up north
the night king and his army are
approaching the last hearth the castle
was then completely over ran by White's
and is destroyed by the night king and
Viserion
bran leaves the vision shaken up he
tells Jon what he just saw John tells
Gendry to make as many weapons as
possible they will need them soon Cersei
Lannister loses her baby due to a
miscarriage it further proves Maggie the
frogs prophecy Cersei is utterly
devastated by this and what else the
prophecy may have in store for her the
golden company begin to march to
Winterfell led by Sir Gregor Clegane
they have dozens of ballistas with them
in their party brain Stark has a vision
about the Isle of faces at the gods eye
he tells John that he needs to go there
bran leaves for the gods eye at the end
of the episode he is protected and
carried by northern soldiers season 8
episode 3 this episode begins with a
code open the first of many Valyrian
steel swords is forged by kendry
Daenerys wants to execute Jaime
Lannister because he killed Daenerys his
father the Mad King Tyrion intervenes
and he tells Daenerys she will have to
kill him too if she insists on killing
his brother
but Jamie then reveals the real reason
why he killed the Mad King now that your
own kept this promise by delivering the
golden company Cersei pays her debt by
marrying euron greyjoy
she knows she can't afford to lose any
alliances now that Jaime is gone
Daenerys realizes she is pregnant but
she decides not to tell John yet so that
she can continue to help fighting the
mountain arrives at Winterfell with the
golden company Arya kills the leader of
the golden company it takes his face
with his face aurilla tries to kill the
mountain who is still on her list she
fails and gets badly injured during the
attack the hound steps in before Arya is
killed the how nearly wins the fight but
his regular steel sword does not kill
the mountain in the last moment the
Hound takes arias Valyrian steel dagger
off her hip the Valyrian steel dagger
kills the mountain as Arya begins to
pass out a soldier of the golden company
sneaks into the nearest 10th outside of
Winterfell the soldier reveals that he
is Daario naharis who joined the golden
company to have the chance to come to
Westeros Daario warns Daenerys about
Circe's plan to have Daenerys and her
dragons killed by the golden company and
their ballistas bran arrives on the Isle
of faces and he tries to learn more
about the creation of the White Walkers
in a possible way to defeat them he
realizes he may be able to change time
when he remembered his father heard him
at the Tower of joy he comes to the
conclusion that the only way to win this
war is to go back in time and prevent
the night king from being created
Daenerys orders the Dothraki soldiers to
kill all of the golden company since
Daario revealed Circe's true plan
Daenerys can't use her dragons to kill
the golden company herself because of
their ballistas a battle breaks out but
the Dothraki are able to slaughter most
of the golden company some of the men
from the golden company capture Jaime
Lannister and they ride off to white
Harbor where some of Euron's fleet
awaits them they had orders to bring
Jaime back to King's Landing alive Arya
Stark is still badly injured from her
fight against the mountain
the maester at Winterfell tells Jon
there is nothing he can do to prevent
her from dying
Melisandre arrives in Winterfell from
volantis Davos wants her executed
immediately but she promises she
can save Aria she remembers Aria from
years ago John allows her to help Aria
which she does but Aria will not be able
to help fight for quite some time
Jorah and Daario volunteered a ride
through the night to King's Landing to
try and free Jaime Lannister Varys gives
them plans about how they can enter the
city through the tunnels under the city
Varys still has a copy of the map him
and Tyrion used before the Battle of
Blackwater Bay
the golden company arrived in King's
Landing with Jaime he is greeted by
euron greyjoy who then escorts Jaime
into the red keep Euron is told to leave
while Cersei tells Jaime that him being
captured was a trap in hopes of luring
Daenerys to King's Landing in case the
first plan failed
Cersei plans on burning the entire city
when they arrive
Jaime is disgusted by this revelation so
he grabs Cersei around the throat and
strangles her to death
Joran then enters the room laughing and
clapping he has Jaime thrown into the
black cells where Ned Stark was Jorah
and Daario arrive in King's Landing
prepared to break Jaime Lannister free
but their escape mission fails
Euron has Daario killed immediately and
he captures Jorah and he has him
imprisoned in the black cells as well
Melisandre goes to Jon in Winterfell
courtyard
Melisandre tells John that while she was
in volantis she saw something disturbing
in the flames she says she saw a boy
wolf tied to a weirwood tree she
proceeds to tell Jon that this boy wolf
is the great others champion she says
his name is Brandon Jon is enraged by
what Melisandre is saying so he
sentences her to death Melisandre asks
for death by fire she says it is the
purest death Daenerys obliges Davos
watches with princess shereen's burnt
stag in his hand
now that Cersei is dead Iran declares
himself king of the Seven Kingdoms with
Khyber neighs his hand
Euron has a letter prepared for Daenerys
Cersei is dead he has Jorah Jaime Yara
and Theon as his prisoners he wants
Damaris to come to King's Landing to be
his new queen if she declines he
promises to send an heiress all of his
prisoners heads Dany refuses his offer
anyway
she vows to kill you're on and set them
free season 8 episode 5 episode begins
with bran going back in time he wargs
into a man so that he can stop the
children of the forest from creating the
night king bran wants to warn them about
what they will cause but they gag him
and bound him to a tree
Brandeis is the man he Ward into is the
same man they turned into the night king
lief begins to plunge the dragon glass
into his chest the night Kings
necromancy powers are actually brands
working powers but even more powerful
what the dragon glass in him Brian can't
manage to come back out of his vision
his eyes stay white now that he has
stuck in the past
Euron brings his prisoners outside to
the septa Bay Lord to begin his public
executions Euron has Yara burned alive
with wildfire while Theon strangles
himself to death trying to save her this
was the same thing the Mad King did to
the Starks during Robert's rebellion
Jorah Mormont has then beheaded
Joran sends his head to Daenerys Jaime
is forced to watch everything Daenerys
is infuriated when she finds out what
you're on dead against the advice of
John and Tyrion she flies what drug on
to King's Landing to kill your own after
Daenerys has left for King's Landing
they receive Ward at Winterfell that the
night king has destroyed karhold and
he's likely heading to the dreadfort or
Winterfell next jon is distraught
because Daenerys has now taken drug on
to King's Landing
he has winterfell's defenses prepared in
every man woman and child armed with
dragonglass and Valyrian steel weapons
Daenerys arrives over top of Blackwater
Bay she burned gerunds fleet immediately
she then flies over the Red Keep and
starts burning everything in sight
Daenerys is mostly in a blind rage due
to Jorah Mormont's death she burns most
of the city down until she starts to
hear the screams of innocent people
being burned alive suddenly she seems to
snap out of her rage so she lands drogon
and is shocked by the destruction she
has caused Daenerys begins to walk
through the Great Hall that is now
completely destroyed snow begins to fall
through the broken and burn roof
Daenerys walks toward the iron throne
that has now covered an
snow she reaches out to touch the thing
she has wanted her whole life but drogon
begins to scream outside of the Great
Hall Daenerys realizes how much snow is
falling in King's Landing the night King
must be getting closer she flies back to
Winterfell realizing that hundreds of
thousands may have died because of her
the last scene shows Euron leaving on an
unmarked ship with Jamie and Qyburn
Euron knew Daenerys would be coming so
they hid underground at King's Landing
what Jamie's still in Chains season 8
episode six
Daenerys arrives back in Winterfell at
the beginning of the episode Tyrion asks
her what happened to his brother and
Euron Daenerys says they are all dead
Jon gathers all of the soldiers and
their weapons to prepare them for the
fight against the army of the Dead a
snowstorm begins to come in over
Winterfell the army of the Dead come
with it the night King leading them on
Vasari on Daenerys mounts drogon to
fight the night king and Viserion
there is a dance of dragons over
Winterfell but dragons fire does not
appear to hurt Vasari on
or the night king vissarion's blue flame
hits drug on and Dany Daenerys is
knocked off drag on it begins to fall
but jørgen saves her by protecting her
with his own body then I king lands to
kill Daenerys but John intervenes he
hits him with Longclaw but it does not
affect him reg all lands to protect them
both
John mounts regal with Daenerys who is
now unconscious from the fall the night
King kills drug on with vissarion's blue
flame John uses regel to burn Jurgens
dead body so the night king can trace
him as well John lands reg also he can
save Sansa Arya Tyrion and some others
before Winterfell was overrun with
whites with everyone now on Ragle Jon
flees Winterfell and heads toward the
gods I where brain said he was going as
they escaped on Ragle Sansa looks back
and begins to cry as she witnesses the
night king destroying Winterfell with
Viserion in all the whites and White
Walkers slaughtering their men the night
King and White Walkers then head for the
crypts of Winterfell where all the dead
kings of winter lay the night king
places his hand on the ground and all
the statues begin to rumble and crack
behind some of the statues all you can
see are
of ice that begin to glow in the
darkness tormund grey worm the hound and
most of the other men stayed behind to
fight the army of the dead while John
and the others escaped on ragle they all
died as they tried to defend Winterfell
from the dead as they approached the
gods ion Ragle they spot bran laying on
the ground next to a weirwood tree John
lands regel and Daenerys awakens in pain
as she is going into labor very early
John has no idea because Daenerys did
not tell him nor could he tell what
Daenerys is heavy clothing on Daenerys
is very weakened by the fall and giving
birth she knows she is not going to
survive she then gives birth to a
premature baby girl she whispers to John
that she wants the baby to be called
leona after the woman her brother died
for John tells Daenerys that was his
mother's name right as she begins to die
after Daenerys dies John takes the baby
and carries her over to where brain is
it appears that bran is still in a
vision but when John looks in the brains
eyes they are blue like the night Kings
instead of white as John is looking at
brand wondering what is happening a
storm begins to roll over the gods I the
night king has arrived on Vasari on John
mounts regal and meets the night king in
the sky
the dance of dragons begin over the gods
I rhaegal and Viserion begin to shoot
flames so close to each other that John
can feel the blue flame for a moment
John and the night king share another
look and John notices the night King's
eyes are exactly like brands are now ray
calls fire does nothing to Vasari on or
the night King John knows in order to
kill the night king he is gonna have to
kill his brother brand John begins to
cry as he lands the dragon near brands
body john climbs off regal and
unsheathed his sword Longclaw
as john is doing this the night king is
circling back toward him on Vasari on
for a moment john contemplates if this
is the right thing to do or not but he
then sees the night king coming right
for him so he plunges Longclaw into
brains heart and the sword catches on
fire and begins to glow red when John
does this the night King and Viserion
simultaneously explode into a thousand
pieces of ice like the White Walkers did
when he had killed
before the screen will then go black for
a moment the next and final scene will
be months later there will be a shot of
King's Landing completely destroyed but
being repaired there will be a shot of
castles in the North completely
destroyed but being rebuilt then finally
a shot of Winterfell almost all of the
snow is now melted away
John is holding baby Liana in Hassan's
ax Arya Tyrion Davos Gendry Brienne and
a few others
John is now the king of the Seven
Kingdoms but he tells everyone there
will no longer be one king for Seven
Kingdoms each kingdom will be
independent
Gendry is legitimized in given storm's
end
Tyrion has given Casterly Rock Sean's is
given Winterfell in Brienne is given
Highgarden
Arya says she doesn't want a castle she
says she's going west
this makes Jon smile John says he has
somewhere he wants to go to he wants
Liana to see Ned and his mother John and
baby Liana had four the crypts of
Winterfell most of the statues are still
destroyed but repairs are being made
John stops in front of leiana's crack
statue and inside he sees a harp with
baby Leona in his arms
John has a smile on his face and a tear
in his eye he sits down and begins to
pluck at the strings and he sings Liana
a song as the episode ends euron greyjoy
and Jamie Lannister are never heard from
again
they are presumably dead
[Music]
[Music]